because there's a pattern to everything
the key to empowerment is understanding
what the pattern is of that thing
whether it's our finances our
relationships our health is always a
pattern behind success or failure and in
the ancient world they understood that
these patterns also exist for
understanding who am I why am I here
what is the purpose of this current
Incarnation we can just while away our
time here and not have it add up to much
of anything and we're no more advanced
at the time of death than we were when
we came here in the first place or we
can do some really serious development
work with our Consciousness and energy
and become more than we were before if
you do not use this lifetime for
advancing your state and you don't
understand the patterns of life then
basically you're just going to be
condemned to keep repeating the same
mistakes and you're going to repeat
yourself to an endless cycle of
suffering so that's one of the main
Concepts in Buddhism is how much
unnecessary suffering are we exposing
ourselves to by not striving for
enlightenment